twice they won the title for the most
beautiful Orange Street in the
Netherlands now they are aiming for a
third time for the past five weeks Danny
and Raymond suenus and their neighbors
have been decorating their street in The
Hague
trying to break their own record by
putting up 50 kilometers of orange Flags
we are fanatical supporters of the
orange team we believe in the
Netherlands We Believe In Coach Louis
van Hall this year it just has to happen
and it will we will be the next world
champions
yeah last year King Willem Alexander
visited this tree to hand over the
special street sign the king is holding
this sign and we're standing on this
this spot and the King gave it the this
thing to us and we are requiring like
like shelter are we so happy the Dutch
team never won the World Cup although it
made it to the final three times in 1974
78 and last in 2010.
but their supporters have never given up
hope while orange fever is on the rise
the mood is different here this world
cup some blame it on the season saying
the tournament should be held during the
northern summer but others are troubled
by accusations of Poor Labor conditions
in the host nation Qatar
some have called for a boycott of the
World Cup by not putting on public
viewings in bars and restaurants several
servers in Germany have shown that a
majority of those asked are in favor of
such a boycott Tobias Epping is a bar
owner in Bonn who has decided not to
show any matches he said it's enough the
number of workers killed stadiums that
are air conditioning during times like
this and she can't even drink a beer
which for me as a bar owner obviously is
a part of it no we cannot longer support
that
supporters in the Orange Street and the
Hague don't agree with such a boycott if
you ask me if I feel bad of the people
dying there of course we do but I think
it's more political political thing
when they play we do this if they if
they want to boycott it then the coffee
Bay shouldn't have sent them
while the Dutch team has left for Qatar
residents of Orange Street are preparing
for their first World Cup in Winter
hoping that the achievements of their
Idols will be enough to keep them warm
step fast in Al Jazeera they hate